is great we'll say he's going to be the
most difficult one to train with
you know because we don't know we don't
know
how his joints are going to work don't
we
do i mean
i'm going to go
all right better mechanical with george
but as long as now
as he comes out
i don't threaten him
see my fingers are there i'm not
threatening him
i'm just
i'm just with him
i mean whatever george wants to do
will do
oh look i'm getting out the his way i'm
getting out of his way
i'm getting out of george's way
um that's why i say i'm a puppet of
him but really i'm the one instructing
him because i'm going over here thanks
so even though i'm looking there of
course i know where i'm going here
because i'm feeling where he's going
you know i can if i go like this and i
go i want you over here all right no i
went over here
then i'm in that middle position of not
knowing
where i'm going what i should have done
is gone takamusu
all right
takamusa is a creation of a technique
that will be born out of the instant not
the mind
takamusu is born from the incident not
see i didn't know i was going to go
there it was only that i
when i done that i can talk you through
it because i was
i can multitask
i wanted to go over here
but i knew that the connection would be
lost
so tony technically
wanted to go over here but i thought i'm
thinking about extending now
anywhere
so what i done was i went like that and
i thought oh all right well i didn't
want to go that way personally but
that was the way
that i felt it needed to be led
so it's difficult for all of you because
you're still working on what i call the
technical so you'll go here and you'll
go right right remember that remember
keep your torso up straight that's it
push down here look good okay next
technique and so you're like
you know you're like these technical
robots because that's what we need you
to be
but what i'm trying to do now is give
you something
that you can say i'll work with that but
all right my own time and i'll and i'll
just go
and i'll work with that in my own time
and
see where where it takes me
all right and if it gives you a
ego boost then so bit and hopefully
you'll get over that and you'll then
see
see i use i do heat i don't now but i do
healing work as well because i can see
where the problem is in somebody's body
because it's
it's like i sense his elbows a little
bit playing up
which i mean it's like so you start
actually seeing points
but it's all lead
it's all led from
this
i don't know what's going to come out of
it
push
that's it good push
right so
um
do we have any questions time's going
no no no no so when you're saying um
yes what happens is technique that's
what i was explaining your technical
ability
jumped in
so when you go
shall i buy this new phone or not you're
standing in the shop say or you're
thinking about shall i buy this new
phone or not you already know the answer
but you wanted to now think about it
sensibly i could get one cheaper cannot
do i mean you start talking about you
start breaking it down well say in a
technical way in other words
tony starts deciding with his conscious
mind
your sock your subconscious mind your
astral body you know and all that
already knew the answer
it knew that you wanted the phone you
just didn't want to
face up to letting your ego saying i've
got an iphone
so what it cost a thousand pounds so
what i wanted it so you have to then go
through all those oh there you go got a
little carried away there you know i
wanted to boast but didn't want to boast
so it's the same thing when you're doing
technical you go in you go in
and out like i'm in the way of this now
for me to do an error i've got to get
out of the way
so i'm in the what i call the astral
plane
i'm in
the astral plane
let's say i'm going to make a mistake so
let's say i get about here and i'm in
the astral plane but he's not playing
with this the astral plane
i'm not in the way because
i'm over here
i'm not in the way i'll change direction
no you can't do that so what you do is
you play a trick and you start doing
what i call a technical get out
and i'm telling you all this stuff
because if you want to expand your
psychic abilities or whatever you want
to go if you want to expand this part of
those senses art
you need to be honest with yourself and
go
i had to do that
because that weren't going to work
unless i did
and you're honest with yourself you say
to yourself i'm going to keep working so
that it i don't have to use that and i'm
going to reduce and reduce and reduce
until i become what i call
a well-being teacher where i actually
done the technique he doesn't mind
training with me
we both go off happy we had a real good
training
it can be awesome it can be hard it can
be fast it can be powerful it can do
everything as long as you don't have bad
intentions up here
okay
so what i'm understanding is that um
to mentally mentally get out of the way
we're becoming more fluid and
the timing and connection is more subtle
and the
my writers say that the
technical
mechanical bits
become
do i say less
important than the connectivity and the
timing yes
yes they're less important but you need
the technical
for the self-defense part
you need the energy
for your own spiritual growth
if you want you know if you want all the
pieces to o senses art
then you need to know what i'm telling
you tonight but you might not choose to
take it
um
[Music]
most of the teachers
who i know
don't believe in this they think it's
rubbish
they're not even interested they just
would rather just do technical technical
technical
but i do it because
i find it fascinating
you know if i if i let's say um that's
right where's danny
danny
if i
when he lifts his hand
i feel that going through me like this
it's like that finger
you know
so he moves me where i now need to be
and that measurement
cannot be wrong
if i do it technically and i'm here and
i go happy
then i might think to myself
i need a bit more weight on the back
foot i need i need i need to actually be
closer you know you all get that don't
you you know you all get that i need to
because what happened is you put
yourself in there under some duress some
slight
gotcha
but you might not think about it and
you'll throw them you'll have a good
time but you'll know that quick flash
second you were in the wrong place but
you got over it and you had fun
but something will say i got it wrong
just there just say i got it wrong
where if i'm connected to him i can't
get it wrong
because i moved
is it actually i i move i'm
i chose that
but why i chose it was because of this
do it let's do it really slow really
slow look as he comes he turns
so i didn't mean to do it i didn't set
it up but i got caught i wanted to do
that
but i got his body you know
that turned me
so that's how far you can go and and i
think that's quite an exciting place to
go
if you you know if you for you know once
a year or whenever you want to do it you
try and you go
great
you know and you're there and you're you
look like you're ready but really
but really you're he was he was never
he was never
away from you
you know
so i don't know what i was doing i don't
know where i was going
of course you're not going to get that
like that so we'll end up with a coke
dozer where you can feel this and so
if he takes in the standard place
you come here
and you know that one but if he takes
underneath
then we've got the
the ken that i was telling you about
with the ken because here he's already
got me high
so if i try and go down i'm against this
physical now so what they do is they
bring them forward and that
that takes a little bit of
you know dropping so what i'm going to
do is i'm going to give him my hands and
as he grips them i want to go down and
into him the same as i held the can so
you see like that we call it cokey don't
we but what i done really was i locked
so push
lift
so so
you've already
got them so i'm showing you this so you
can see it what if i don't show you that
so i mean
so that's not showing it
that's showing it
but you see he's wondering now i can
pick up his waves on his thinking he's
wondering if he can actually
win this one
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
send him in a different direction
because to the one he thinks he's gonna
win at
so he's gonna grab you're gonna grab
each other underneath
you're gonna choose
a side
that you're going to throw in
and because i didn't have a side
because i was busy making a side
he didn't go
right and quite rightly like jenny says
sometimes it's too quick
to um
to decide
what i'm doing now is i'm just
cheating if you like and i'm watch his
hand
i'm doing that before he gets there
all right let's try
come on
i hope we got some reasonable
stuff on there
good good because i was a bit
disappointed with the battery
uh life but um
that's good
because he wasn't here obviously
yeah
oh well it looked nice like what i was
saying on video but i i said i i got it
wrong thinking it was
that's the trouble you see because i'm
not here all the time i thought it was a
week before that you done the
certificates not that not the night
sebash was supposed to be coming no we
did the great that was a week later